i know that
we have to wrap up at some point soon
and i wanted to bring this up i didn't
know how
but i'll just tell you quickly the a few
months ago maybe i'll even take this out
of the
actual clip but a few months ago january
february i was
i woke up in the middle of the night and
then i had a conversation with my wife
it was minor
neutral wasn't positive or negative and
then as i was going back to sleep she
either said yes or okay
or she could have not said it but i was
in this hypnagogic
almost sleep-like state and i've never
had a panic attack in my life
but for some reason i wasn't sure if she
said okay or yes or whatever it was or
if it was in my own head
and then i thought am i am i psychotic
am i getting
schizophrenia i don't know why it's not
like that was a background anxiety of
mine before
maybe it was maybe it's latent but then
i started to have a panic attack
because i didn't want to hear anything
and i felt like i may be
able to will myself to hear something by
telling myself
don't hear then i'm like well what would
it sound like if i were to hear
then it's like no no don't go down there
because you may hear a voice
and i don't want to go i don't want to
be crazy i don't want to be psychotic
a couple days later i had another panic
attack almost based on the
worry that i'm going to be psychotic
rather than i
am at all and and i'm i've been afraid
to search
about schizophrenia because i don't want
to read that i have the symptoms of it
and
there's nothing else other than that i
may have heard my wife say okay or yes
in a state where i was
about to sleep and that she actually may
have in fact said it
or not i talked to my doctor about this
on the phone because it's
kovid and she said oh kurt well you can
hear many things you can hear
music when you're about to sleep you can
your foot can feel like you're about to
fall off and you
so don't worry about that and i found
that when i talk about it i feel much
more at ease
but ever since then for three months
carl for
three months at night time i've had such
a difficult time falling asleep
because i'm afraid of my own mind i
can't let myself be alone with my own
thoughts because i'm afraid of what i
might find
and it's created such anxiety in me that
i well i can't rely on any
benzodiazepine to sleep because that can
just put you in a
that'll create way worse problems so i
have to find some way of sleeping
without any
medication besides maybe melatonin
that's difficult
and i'm just not sure what to do with
that issue i brought this up on one of
my podcasts
because i feel like there are plenty of
people who may be experiencing what i'm
experiencing
but but people don't talk about it it
turns out when i did talk about it many
people in the comments section said
i can't believe you've been going
through this that's i've been going
through something similar
when i study about consciousness and so
on for this
for these types of interviews i feel
like i don't know what reality is
anymore because there's so many
different theories
and so that is destabilizing me on top
of what i've already been feeling and
i'm unsure what to do about it
and i just want to know what what advice
do you have i know that that's
extremely personal question but what
what do you recommend that i do
or not do well if ironically you've just
done it
um um so um
now i i i'm responding as in my role as
a psychiatrist free energy principle
although
much of the free energy principle was
actually inspired by
exactly the questions that you're
contending with you know
how do i maintain a sense of self
which is the most important part of my
narratives
explain explain me and what can go wrong
when you have
um psychosis i think the first thing to
say
is that there
[Music]
have been an enormous number of people
around the world during lockdown and
during the coronavirus crisis with
reduced
social contacts and changing points of
reference so
your old narratives your old models are
just not fit for purpose
and in a sense you've got to be able to
grieve for the things
that you know the way that things were
and it's quite
frightening to actually relearn how to
live even for a few months
um you know in an in a new covered world
and certainly if there's been
um you know so changes in in social
distancing on the way that you interact
with people
and i should say also when and if
you um have to unlock that will also be
very you know
anxiety provoking as well because of the
uncertainty you've got to re-learn how
to do it
so lots of my colleagues have had um
psychotic breaks
um and you i i talking to you i think
it's highly unlikely that you have any
form of psychosis
or indeed an acute psychotic episode
just by your composure
your theory of mind a lot of other
non-verbal cues
however i do have many colleagues who've
actually had an acute psychotic episode
uh in response to this um i haven't but
you know a lot of my close qualities
have
um and it's perfectly natural
they usually last about sort of um you
know sort of
a few weeks to a month or two may
respond to medication if if
if the person is becoming sufficiently
agitated or they're worrying their
their close family um you know
it needs containment pharmacologically
that's certainly
viable if it gets that far usually it
doesn't
but the important thing to know is this
is perfectly normal you know
even if you haven't had a psychotic
episode if you had had
lots of people are going through this
which brings me to
the answer to your question um you can
certainly talk to your gp
um and talk to healthcare professionals
and mental health care
professionals and there will be the
option
of um medication uh either to help with
sleep or
to if you actually did have a psychotic
um
break to take the edge off that and
enable everybody to cope with you know
with the consequences that's always an
option should you want to go for it and
you shouldn't feel
ashamed of doing that or in any way
hesitant
i have to say that the nature of these
episodes is such that it won't be the
person
who has the psychotic episode who knows
that they
um they need containment and looking
after of a particular kind
it's usually the the next of kin their
children their parents
or their wife or their husband uh who
has to take the initiative to to bring
in support and help to get that done
and that help is there the very fact
you're worrying about it
because you're you're almost by
definition it
can't be psychotic because you you've
got inside uh so
just by worrying about it i'm afraid uh
takes you off of that list um
but it doesn't mean to say the anxiety
doesn't go away but it doesn't mean you
can't
you're not actually uh psychotic and the
other thing which which
really helps um is just what you've
already said
it it's basically sharing in the group
so you know
the angst that these things generate and
you know whether it's a psychotic break
or not always worrying about it or not
everybody's going through this um and
being able to share that in a group
is a can be enormously therapeutic
for everybody in in the group indeed you
know so if you can set up
by sharing a safe environment within
which
to share these experiences and anxieties
and by safe i mean very clearly bounded
so it starts at a particular time and it
finishes exactly
one hour later so you've got this
boundary so that
anything that comes out in that context
can't spill over
and affect um and can be put back in the
box
but you know there's going to be a box
next week or tomorrow
with a very very carefree time you know
who's going to be there
or you know what kind of people are
going to be there so boundaries are very
very important when it comes to group
therapy that
that in my in my experience that's the
most effective
kind of talking therapy in this
situation how do you get a group
together
you have to say well this is a thing
how do you do that you just have to
declare you have to come out say i'm
upset by this i can't get to sleep
because of this this you know
you know if i'd told myself these
worries a year ago i thought i was
stupid but these are real worries
they're stopping me
thinking i can't you know just saying
that out loud
means that other people now are aware
that this is a thing
and it's something that can be talked
about so when i said you've just done it
by just going public in this kind of
interview
is the first move the next move is then
to find
um you know a a network um
or a structure that will support um
either therapist-led or self-help groups
usually
small enough that you actually have um
the
the intimacy of a small group dynamic
you you're so not more than 12
people you usually about eight people
with or without a therapist
you don't need the therapist but it's
useful um you know if somebody is
just to get used to the importance of
boundaries
and you know and group dynamics but it's
not necessary if
you know the important things you're
getting together in a bounded way
um to to you know to to share and
um and to just in a completely open and
non-judgmental way
and tell other people how what they are
saying makes you feel
um and just use them to reflect
literally like a mirror
you know so you come back to the shared
narrative again and you can
you can get a long way with that so um
that that's what i would recommend
that you you you know somebody in your
position
may well feel that perhaps you should
start an initiative along these lines or
actually start
you you should take the initiative and
actually set up
a discussion group or a self-help group
but if not then certainly look around on
the web and i'm sure you'll find
um you know some somebody over the past
few months
um and uh we will have started this
um and be mindful
that you should tell your wife
if you do get a psychotic just kind of
get the doctors into
to get you medicated because that'll go
away in about three weeks once you
you know if you just take take the right
kind of medication it's not a big thing
i repeat it's happened to several of my
colleagues and friends
um and you know they're back in the
saddle now
and it's been a useful experience
sometimes people get um
they get more creative